تويتر يحتضر نحن نشهد نهايه احد اهم افضل
من الصوت التواصل بسبب غرور الى الماسك
واعجابه بذاته وقراراته المندفعه هكذا يرى
كثيرون من منتقدي ماسك الغرور بجانب
الاداره المنفرده سبب موجه من عدم
الاستقرار داخل منصه سواء على مستوى
الاداره الداخليه او من ناحيتي تجربه
المستخدم الى الماسك صراحه اكثر من نصف
موظفي تويتر بعد استحواذيه على الشركه في
اكتوبر الماضي ويقول ان الفتره المقبله
اصعب وحاليا يخير الموظفين الناجين من
مجزره الاقالات بين العمل لفترات طويله هو
تحت ضغط شديد او الرحيل
اعترض على خطته ورفض ظروف العمل المرعبه
التي تنتظرهم من اجل تصميم نسخه جديده
تماما من تويتر تويتر
ضبابيه التي يقال انه لم يشاركها حتى معلم
مهندسين الرئيسيين ورؤوس الحب في الشركه
والمئات قدموا استقا بالفعل يخسر ماسك
الموظفين مفصولين او يسخر منهم علنا على
حسابه يعتذر عن فصل العباقره ويقول ان
موهبهم ستكون مفيده في مكان اخر لكنه في
نفس الوقت يفتح باب التوظيف لاضافه دماء
جديده لكن الموظفين الاكثفاء مترددون فمن
يريد الابحار على سفينه تغرق